it's the crew of the bebop what's going
on everyone good to see you all
what's up bro
this is exciting as an anime fan as as
like a long time fan of cowboy bebop i
almost never thought i'd see this in
live action
john what were the challenges that you
thought about like
about adapting something so beloved into
a new medium
um the first challenge was probably you
know the the martial arts and
and and getting
proficient enough to be able to to to
participate in in those fights um
so that was it and
that's where we started that was the
most important thing for me um
and then it was um
really understanding it was once we got
to new zealand where we shot and we got
the full back story of the characters
where really
it felt like uh
the the roof was opening and all the sun
was shining in on the character work
that we're going to have to do so
um
yeah
daniella what would you say that
new people new to the series can expect
from cowboy bebop
um i think it's going to be
uh may am i allowed to curse
please do it's going to be
fun
and i think people are going to have the
best escape and it's going to be a good
binge and um i think that uh
you know it's you get a little bit of
everything tonally genre-wise like i
think there's something in it for
everyone and i'm not even just saying
that i mean really our show goes so many
different places so um and even from our
score yoko has jazz but she also has
things that are really like contemporary
and futuristic so i just think there's
something in it for everybody
yeah yeah
and you know the chemistry
is so important between these three
characters and you you have it the three
of you absolutely have it mustafa what
was it like because it it seems like you
guys especially with scenes with um jet
and spike that it looks like you guys
are just having the best time out there
is that what it was like on and off
camera
totally i mean me and john would talk
about all kind of crazy stuff you know
we did huh
one side of the spectrum jail it was
like we could literally talk about
anything
um which made passing the time really
easy in the tent
um and so like yeah i think that ability
to gap and connect on a basic level
totally translated in front of the
camera
you know with the words in the mouse
yeah i was gonna say also we we
we went through a lot including the
pandemic and
and
um not that it was specific to us but
you know
shooting in in in another country during
the pandemic and all this stuff and it
took a very long time we took a hiatus
and um
you know by the time we came back so a
lot of those connections weren't like
you know actors
doing stuff it was pretty real it was
earned i'm thinking particularly i was
seeing um moo
uh
at the cathedral at the end there when i
was looking at you
over there when we were tied up i i
it was like that look wasn't between
spike and jet
at some point i was like this is me and
moo looking at each other and it got
real in that moment
yeah i agree
john you're talking about that hiatus
that you took is that due to the you
know the ones that you have to keep you
down because of your injury there
yeah yeah i am i i got a booboo and uh
and i had to go away but uh
thanks to the production netflix for
sticking by me and um
and waiting and thanks to you guys for
waiting on me
i mean nobody else could have played
spike you know one yeah once we saw it
all the connections the chemistry just a
no-brainer
now you know each of your personalities
the characters personalities are so
strong who do you like as an individual
each of you who do you actually relate
to the most
john
[Music]
actually half
half a half
half jet i i and that's why it it
that's why there are sparks because i
think there is a lot of
crossover between spike and and pay and
john and daniella and then there's
and then uh the other half is the dad
energy
of uh
danielle you on screen you look like it
looks like you shining through is it do
you just relate to faye the most or am i
am i wrong here i would say i do relate
to pay the most i want to be jet black
in my professional life
i think that black as is in my career is
where i'd like to go i don't know if i
want to be
i feel like faye in my professional life
would burn out really fast
but no there were there are a lot of
things about her that
are me and in that part um
it feels like a glove
it's not i don't have to veer very far
to kind of to get her which was so fun
yeah and and like
they're all so cool jed is so cool but
mustafa finally like do you see
uh faye a bit of faye and spike in
yourself
absolutely um jung would say that every
everything in the dream is the dreamer
so i feel like you know i can see myself
in all the aspects of the reality in
front of
um and especially in those two
characters like there's so much of spite
that i can relate to personally in my
own right definitely i'm like
i totally have that lazy fair nonchalant
attitude about things
um you know amongst other things rough
pasture
excellent well it's been a pleasure
chatting with you uh huge fan thank you
so much for the time all the best thank
you
you